Hello Hello大家好，欢迎来到我们的频道主流之外，我是主播布丁，我是主播环环。
不知道大家知不知道，今年的三福天是从7月15日就要开始了，
近福就代表着一年当中最热的一段日子就要开始了，每一福十天，一共是30天，你知道吗？
你猜呢，我在中医院上吧，去年我们还给大家讲过怎么度过夏天的健康方面的指示，
回述一下我们的节目，大家感兴趣的话。
嗯，那你知道三福天都有哪些顺口流儿吗？
那不知道，这应该是你的领域。
叫什么，头服饺子，二服面，头服的时候吃饺子，二服的时候吃面，头服第一天和二服第一天的时候。
还有一个说法是，衣服热似火，二服烤的黄，三服征丧拿。
你有这种感受吗？
每一年的三福天的时候？
有，因为我看新闻说，今年有一个什么尼尔尼诺的那个，类似是一个气候中心发布的这个事件，
说它这个发生的概率超过80%，这个详细的大家可以自己上网搜，
说人话今年会无比的热，超级的热，super热，热过你之前过的每一年。
今年雨水也特别多，我就有种感觉，暴风雨前的那个平静，这种凉快，
下雨之后的这种凉快都不是什么好凉快的感觉。
反正就是感觉，虽然这波雨不是那个恶人泥糯，但是觉得是恶人泥糯的前摇。
对，你知道我在北方和南方带之后，我就有种感觉，北方的热是烤炉里的那种热，
但是在南方的热就真的是争丧拿，你喘不来气，生生哎呦，我真的是太不舒服了，
失路路的那种感觉，就导致我的皮肤真的非常的敏感，我之前在北方的时候感受还不这么明显，
但是到了南方以后，我就发现我的皮肤真的尤其一到夏天的时候敏感的不要不要的。
因为你之前在北方，只是高温和强子外线双重加急，你去到南方以后就是高温高湿高子外线三重加急，
它只能是变得更差。
所以我就想啊，我们今天不聊三幅天，也不聊三幅天，我们就聊一聊在这种炎热的夏天的时候，
我们如何护肤，如果真的觉得护肤尤其是夏季的护肤实在是太重要了，
因为你冬天的时候干燥，咱们就是多补水就行，但是夏天就不行，就像你刚才说的高温高湿强子外线三重加急，
就是我护完这里护那里，护完那里护这里。
所以呢，咱们这期就给大家好好讲一下护肤，但是咱们毕竟不是美妆啊，或者是美容护肤类的这个博主，
所以咱们就是从健康就如何让你的皮肤健康且舒适的度过这个夏天来做一个相当于是健康的宣导，
夏天就四句话，防晒打底，控油别堵，补水锁住，舒缓别足，咱们先给大家一个大肢的概况，
接下来就慢慢给大家说，讲戏说每一点之前我先给大家铺一个底层的逻辑，
为什么这个高温的季节皮肤的问题发生的概率会比其他季节会高一些，
因为正常情况下温度每升高一度，咱们这个皮脂线的分泌速度它是会涨10%，
这个是写在咱们这个教材里的，加上刚刚布丁说的夏季嘛，特别是南方，普遍湿度比较大，
像北方空气湿度不大情况，你也会出汗嘛，这样就会导致你皮肤表面的一些菌群增值速度又会提升40%，
所以这也不是什么奇怪的问题，它就是一个物理加微生物的一个双重的暴击，
就导致了高温季节皮肤的问题发生率会比其他季节高出40%，
这个是基于一些临床皮肤科的一个流行病学的调查，
那我们今天就按照我们正常的一个互富的流程给大家走一遍，
我们在每一步需要做的和需要注意的事情，那首先第一步最重要的就是清洁，
也就是我们俗称的洗脸，我觉得真的洗脸这一块真是太重要了，
因为首先你清洁不到位，你洗不好的话，你后面做的所有的事情全部都是零，
大家也千万别过度清洁，清洁过了其实也不行，
那我就先跟大家说一下怎么正确的清洁，首先记住五个字，温和且彻底，
怎么叫做温和且彻底呢？
第一个就是早上洗脸的时候就用清水或者是温和的那种安基酸的产品来解面，
千万千万不要过度清洁，那夜间的话，
如果你要是化了妆或者是做了仿晒的话，一定要先卸妆，然后再去用解面乳去清洗，
尤其重点要清洁的是我们的T区，那水温呢我建议是在32到35度的温水，
不要太凉也不要太热，切记不要冷热水交替的去洗脸，这样是不对的，
一天洗脸就洗两次就可以了，早上咱们就清除夜间的带些物，
晚上我们就去除化妆品，这种防晒乳，这种残留和物购就可以了，
不要一天洗八辈儿脸，其实也不用这么过度的清洁，
不定这个讲的真的不知道大家听感怎么样，我感觉应该是覆盖了很多网上曾经或者现在还在流行的一些清洗物曲，
特别是刚刚你说那个冷热交替洗脸，错重了，我小时候就经常这样，
甚至还会怕那个冷的水不够冷，我还专门冻点冰块，热水的时候打开毛孔，让我们的清洁更到位，
清洁到位之后一定要用冷水洗脸，因为冷水可以把毛孔搜缩，我小时候就这么被骗我，
但我现在跟大家严重辟谣，这个是非常不科学的，当你的这个皮肤的这个环境温度，
如果在五分钟之内，如果轴变十五度的话，小纸层纸质，它会直接变向斜景，你这个屏障就会裂开，
这个是有文献知识的，就是反复的温差刺激，我们刚刚说的冷热水交替洗脸，
精皮的水分流逝量会飙升至48%，不叫护肤，叫热胀冷缩实验，你就相当于把你的脸当一个实验品，
在热胀冷缩反复刺激它，然后那个水分就全流逝了，反正我们医院每年特别是夏天的时候，
经常会有那种皮肤因为冷热水交替洗脸，洗得过激了，然后过来就医的患者，
还真有过，还有的患者比我还过激，我只是把那个冰块放到水里，让那个水更凉一点，
最近我听皮肤可接着了一个，它是，它夏天太热了，然后它去海边晒得很黑，
它就回来贴那个，就是凉的面膜，它嫌不够凉，它贴面膜的时候还拿冰块在脸上一直浮，
结果给脸搞坏了，过来就医，那不就很容易动伤吗？
是的，它就是动伤来的，夏天啊，它接了一个动伤的患者，我们医院圣经院都知道了，
陈建用清水洗脸这个概念，我也是前几年，我才就是了解到和认知到这一点，
确实是，因为我那个时候是有一个皮肤科的同事，来我们科时进修学习，我带着他，
那个小姑娘皮肤好到，就是说她没有多白啊，
但是说她那个皮肤非常的光滑细腻，就感觉吹弹可破，真的是我见过特别好的一个皮肤，
而且她毛孔特别特别的细，我就一直看她，我说你都用的是什么护肤品呢？
她说我脸什么东西都没抹，而且我们要直夜班嘛，那尤其夜班的时候我们更不可能去化妆了啥的，
我说你确定你什么都没抹吗？那你平时是怎么护肤的呢？
她说我平时也很随便，我来都没洗脸，她来上班之前都没有洗脸，我说那你平时也不洗吗？
她说我早上就用清水洗脸，不用那些洗面奶，晚上的时候就可能用一下，
但是早上那边洗脸的时候就从来没用过洗面奶，我说那你就能洗干净吗？
我说那些油质什么的护在脸上，就真的很难清洗掉，如果你只用清水的话，她说其实是可以的，
因为我晚上的时候，我出去一天，我脸上有那些物购什么的，我用洗面奶我给她清洗掉了之后，
我第二天早上起床，我这个脸上其实也就是一些些分泌的油脂，我这些油脂其实有一部分是保护皮肤的，
所以说我不需要全部的把它清洗掉，她平时也没有那种化妆的习惯，很少化妆，
所以说她脸上也没有什么太多的那些化妆品的残留，所以真的她皮肤特别好，我才盖她到她这个概念，
我们俩直班那天晚上她一直在给我磕谱这个皮肤到底怎么回事，我们要怎么护理，
她本身就是皮肤科的嘛，我也不知道是人家来学习，还是我跟人家学习，真的是受益肥浅，
这个班值得赚到了，我们刚刚特意给大家强调，洗脸最好用按计算节面，
就不是给大家说打广告什么的，因为确实市面上有很多造机一类的，
就是她的PA就只是9到10左右的那种，让你洗完以后会感觉脸上特别清爽，紧绷绷的，
好多人就误以为这种才是洗干净的，但其实不是，你正常皮肤你表面的PA就大概是5.5左右，
你用那种造机去洗脸，其实就是在用减水在洗脸，它洗掉的不仅仅是什么油质，
而是你正常皮肤里面天然的保湿因子和皮肤坚纸之间的纸质，就它也是油性的，
就都被这个造机一重就都掉了，所以你会有那种紧绷绷的感觉，就那个坚纸里面的纸质也被洗没了，
就相当于是你一个屏障都被洗掉了，当你的皮肤屏障被洗掉的时候，你一个皮肤它会识别了，
啊，完了完了，屏障没了，它就会启动，说我们现在带长性的去补充这个细胞肩那个被洗掉的那个坚纸，
你就会发生带长性出油，你就会发现你越洗的感觉，哎，我今天怎么油出的就越躲，我就越躲用一点儿这种造机类的，
就形成一个恶性循环，这个在临床上叫反应性皮脂分泌，最后发展到成一个病，就叫清洁过度性皮炎，
如果你总是过度清洁，你会让你的皮肤生病的，是这样的，我以前就有这种毛病，我洗完的脸必须要是紧崩崩的，
一摸就感觉就是那种盘子洗完之后拿手一搓就嘎咨嘎咨响，你知道吗，有那种圣色感，我洗完的脸一定要有那种圣色感，
我今天的脸是洗干净了，要不然我脸洗完是滑滑那种，我就感觉我今天脸没洗干净，就特别不舒服，也是花了好长一段时间，
才把这个概念指入到自己的脑子里，去改变了这个习惯，真的，因为之前我就觉得，哎，我洗完脸之后，我经常会大量的出油，是因为我脸水不够，
有一个概念，我自己给到自己的，我觉得应该有很多人跟我有一样的想法，水油是平衡的，比如说都是一，
如果我水只有0.2的话，那我油就得是0.8，所以我要疯狂的补水，我的油才能下去，因为我那个水的话，比如说补到0.5，那我的油也会0.5，能懂吗，
哎，这一回对数字名岸上了，写修的时候可厉害了我的天，感觉好像这个水油一定是在我这个皮肤层是要平衡的，拿到一种平衡，
所以说我就一定要大量的补水保湿，我就觉得我这个油才不出，但是呢，最后我就变成了水油混合级，水没补好，油也哭哭住，
后来我就学习到了这个缺水和出油，它俩没有直接关系，我就天都塌了，你说它要是有关系吧，它可能也有那么一点点，
但是它绝对不是直接关系，我给大家讲一下是怎么回事，首先你的屏障受损了，你的皮肤屏障受损了，
受损了以后呢，它经皮肤的这个水分流失就会增加，皮肤上的水分流失增加了以后呢，这个皮肤就会感觉到紧绷和干燥，
就相当于你用那个造机，你洗得太过于清洁了之后导致你皮肤的屏障受损，你水分就流失掉了，你就有了这种紧绷和干燥的感觉，
然后呢，身体不舒服了，它为了补充这个表皮水分的流失，它可能会有一点点的油脂，会生理性的，轻微的增加一点点。
它本质的原因不是因为说你这个脸上缺水了，所以说我油才出来的多，本质是你的脸出现了眼症，屏障出现了问题。
这个就是大家经常说的，外油内感，就摸着油，然后但其实本质是你的屏障受损，锁不住水了，皮肤为了弥补这个受损，除了点油，你就感觉啊，我怎么这么油，就是这么回事，然后我们还觉得啊，我们做的是对的，
越油的时候我们越要大力的清洗它，不让它那么油，努力的补水，那其实这些全是没有用的，因为你整个皮肤的屏障是受损的，你知道就越这么做，越这么做，你会把这个皮肤外边的这个脚质层给它弄得很薄，薄了之后你就会发现你的皮肤变成了敏感肌。
皮肤它脚质层本来就很薄，它能存的水本来就很少，这个时候又会有人经常会没事就拿着小喷雾，买那种里面只是纯水的那种喷雾啊，我们就不提牌子了，大家懂了都懂。
就在狂喷，一会儿就喷一会儿，一会儿就喷一点，就会发现越喷越感，原因也是因为你这个脚质层本来就很薄了，它能存的水就很少了。
这种纯水喷在皮肤上蒸发的时候，会把那个本来脚质层上就不多的水分，一起拐得走。就很难，不仅是白喷，还帮了到嘛，非常的悲伤。
我这些说完之后，就也不是说补水保持这一块不重要，补水保持这一块非常非常的重要，但是要怎么补，你才能补上这个水也很重要。
不是说你拿个小喷骨，一喷你就把水补完了，没用，朋友们，真的没有用。咱们健康的皮肤脚质层，含水量是约20%到30%的。
我们补水的话，一定要解面以后，立即补水。你洗完脸以后，你赶紧就把水给护脸。那你选择什么样的水乳呢？我跟大家讲，一定要选择清透型的。
比如说什么波尿酸呢？B5啊？神经纤安呢？就含这些成分的水乳是相对比较好的。
还有一点，你保持一定要室内的湿度要搞。就像是我在南方，我就感觉我不用补水，我皮肤也是QQ弹弹。
但是我回到北方，我就感觉我脑袋上套一个就比起宝那3D的那个太空帽里边装满水，我感觉也没有用。我皮肤还是感到爆皮。
那么泡，谁泡谁爆皮。
真的，就是因为空气的湿度不够大。正常室内的湿度，如果要是低于40度了的话，最好你就弄一个加湿器。理想的湿度是在50%到60%这个样子。
再一个不水保湿的一个凉法就是多喝水。
朋友们，多喝水不仅仅限于你生病感冒发烧的时候，它还限于你皮肤不好的时候，太重要了。
这个喝水大家一定要少量多次啊。就是我反正身边好多同事，但也可能是因为我们这个职业员就忙的时候就忘了。
然后每次喝的时候都渴，这感觉不行要糊弄。这个时候嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟，喝一大堆其实没有效果的。最好的就是少量多次，没觉得渴的时候，没事你就喝点，没事就喝点。
像刚刚布丁说的选择清透性的水乳，真的非常重要，因为我身边好多朋友他们就清透不清透，咱先不说。
他们那个护肤流程非常的荣长，他能在那我感觉护十成，其实这样也是没有意义的。就是你洗完脸以后，趁这个脚尾层还十分的状态，你要么就选拨尿钻，拨尿钻是抓水的。
要不然就是选神经线，神经线是干啥的，你就相当气墙的。你不是说屏障受损了吗，它是能给你恢复屏障的，让你这个墙从一个气起来的。
B5的话，它修复的，就是你一个屏障没有完全破损的时候，它有一些小破损的地方，它是能给你修复的，大家就这么理解就行。
你可以用韩，他们都有的，你也可以用韩其中一个到两个的，因为每个人皮肤的问题的原因是不一样的。
你在这一层一层又一层的话，其实是没有任何意义的，它干不了这么多活儿，你可能也没有这么多的问题。
忽完以后，只会导致我们这个闷的不行了，也不透气了，它就更不能是正常呼吸的一个状态了，就没有什么意义。
而且我跟大家讲一个真实的案例，就是我自己，我刚来南方的时候，我大概半年多以后，突然之间脸上就开始冒痘，就是好多好多的痘，
他们就说这是正常现象，是因为水土不服，我当时就满脸问号，他们说没事，你就千万不要挤这些痘，慢慢的过几个月就好了。
我说得过几个月，半年以后还是满脸冒痘，我用了很多很多方法，后来我就不听他们来了，我就开始用那些去痘的产品，用各种去痘的方法，均没有效果。
这个痘下去了之后，就又起一层，就是很严重。
我也是当时有一次是去澳门，正好改成我一直用的一个护肤的品牌，它搞那个促销有打折活动，我就想给它补补货。
我去了那家店之后，那个贵姐跟我说，她说正常你的这个皮肤用这款其实是很合适的，非常好。
但是你现在的状况就已经用不了它了，因为它这个营养成分太高了，里面用的那些东西，你的皮肤现在已经承受不住这些东西了。
她就给我推荐了另一款产品，那款产品还没有那么贵，还挺好的那一套。
她说你回去试一下，你什么都不要涂，所有的东西你都停掉，你只用这一款，你试一段时间。
你看一下，抱着世世的心态，我就买回来了。
就按照她说的这种做法，什么都不用，只用她给我推荐那一款，真的没多长时间。
我这脸上的痘痘就开始消了，就消掉了之后，可能几个月吧，就很短的一个时间内，我脸上就再也没有痘痘了。
我在后来又持续的用了那个产品一段时间，我给你讲，连半瓶我都没用到，我脸上痘痘就没了。
你看试完，非常好用。
她当时跟我讲的就是，你一定一定要把那些东西全断掉。
因为有的时候，比如说你脸上长了痘痘，尤其夏天的时候，油脂多，就特别爱容易闷痘嘛。
那你其实这个营养相对比较高，眼症也比较高。
那你还在这个上面，你再去给它涂油脂类的呀，这种就是什么高营养，就是你更容易促进这个痘生长。
就大概是这么一个概念啊。
所以说让这个皮肤整个清爽起来，精简护肤是更对皮肤好的。
千万千万不要给这个这么薄薄的一层这个小皮肤再增加负担。
真的很容易导致这个皮肤屏障的这个功能性的受损很严重。
而且在夏天的时候，它温度越高，皮肤的吸收能力就越差。
尤其夏天它非常非常的不适合后涂护肤品。
你要给这个皮肤点儿空间，让它有空间呼吸。
大家很大的一个误区就是觉得我护肤，我知道对我的皮肤非常的好。
什么产品好，什么成分好，我就是猛猛的都给它，这样是不行的。
护肤其实最重要的地方，其实就是保护好你的皮肤，让它能正常的呼吸。
把那些会对它有影响的东西隔绝在我们的皮肤之外，就可以了。
让它自己好好活着就行。
好多皮肤问题，属于是过度的护肤或者过度清洁，就瞎操心操出来的。
对，真的是纯自己瞎做给它做到烂脸的。
夏天的话，基本上现在大家都知道在防晒嘛，
在这个事儿其实不用像几年前就二提面命的一直跟你道道了。
我感觉现在已经没有什么人说，我不怕晒黑，所以不用涂防晒爽。
就这一块刻薄已经做到位了。
但是因为现在大家对自己皮肤都非常好嘛，就导致防晒这个选择上就非常的夸张。
你知道我前两天跟朋友去海边，他们竟然拿出了一个SPIF100的防晒爽，我就惊了。
真的有一百的，我最高就见过五十的呀。
对呀，我觉得去海边五十足够了，但是拿出来一个一百的，我都惊懒了。
我说这是人类用的产品嘛。
你确定这个不是什么假冒伪劣产品，就是说它写一百，其实它没有一百，只是在夸张过度的营销呢？
那反正也有可能。
因为它这个指数越高，它的那个乘模剂和征筹剂放的不就越多嘛。
我觉得它想着SPIF100的话和那个刮墙的逆子有什么变别。
我跟你讲，我真的非常非常不愿意涂防晒，忽忽的活。
忽脸上我就感觉真的脸不透气，油膩膩的，因为我真的不喜欢油膩膩嘛。
你也知道我刚才讲洗脸的你就能感觉到，真的很不舒服让这个脸，它能是那种，就感觉是涂了一层油在脸上。
它能舒服吗？它也真涂，你没试试。
我不跟你说嘛，我当时在我脑袋里，当我想到一百的时候，我就想，嗯，这就是刮墙的逆子。
真的很夸张，其实防晒的话，最简单的就记住一个ABC原则。
A就是Avoid避免日晒，上午十点到下午四点。
紫外线它是有一个强度的那个峰值，避开这段时，就是峰值的那个时间出去烙。
你就感觉太阳不是特别晒，或者其实你自己人就有体感呢。
太阳紫外线特别强的时候，你出去皮肤裸露在外面是有轻微的刺痛感的。
所以就选好这个时间。
第二个是Bblock硬防晒，是永远的神朋友们。
宽眼的帽子呀，UPF什么武林家的那种防晒衣啊，或者是UV400的太阳镜啊，
就这三件套，比多厉害的防晒霜其实都强，
因为你想你涂的那个东西它再怎么能隔绝，
它也不如说是我直接拿个东西隔上，而且本身这个产品它还有抵御紫外线的系数。
它是效果是最强的，AB嘛，C才是cream，就是才是防晒霜。
防晒霜是最后一道的防线，
但是其实如果你能避开这个紫外高峰值，然后出去保证再快点冒，
穿防晒衣，戴那个太阳镜的话，你这个防晒霜其实涂不涂都行，
但是如果你真的是比如说像我前两天去海边，这个就是必须涂的，
或者是我真的是在紫外线非常强的时候出去的，那就一定要涂，
但是千万不要像我那位朋友一样，SPF100，太夸张了。
华为说的这个，咱们在防晒霜啊，或者这些防晒的品牌里面，
经常会提到SPF，这个SPF值到底是什么，
跟大家讲一下，防护中波紫外线UVB，就这个东西的能力，
它可以防晒红啊，防晒香啊，那SPF30是能格决掉约96%的UVB，
到达SPF50的话，基本上就能阻挡98%了，
所以说你SPF100，不知道你要阻挡什么，可能是血鬼，
咱也不知道它是真的有这么强，还是说这个虚假广告做的，
就是要不听完那节目，你再造假也行，可能整一点是吧，
还有一个概念是PA，PA的话是防护长波紫外线UVA的一个能力，
它就是说可以防晒黑和防晒老，也是给到大家这个概念，
那平时我们选用的时候，日常通勤的话，我们就选SPF30加一个加号，
PA三个加号基本上是可以了，就足够了，那如果要是户外活动啊，
你要是去海边啊，或者是什么大草原，高原等等这些地方的话，
你就要选择SPF50加PA要四个加号以上，写防水防害，
因为你在外面的话，你就容易出汗啊什么的，
你就要记得一定要防水防汗型的，这样就可以了，
我们一般情况下是在出门前15到30分钟就给它涂好，
不要涂得太早也不要涂得太晚啊，基本上是一元硬币那么大小，
就可以涂一整个脸了，就差不多那样子，
如果你要是出去户外活动的这样的话，你要没两个小时就补涂一次，
或者是游泳啊或者大量出汗以后呢，一定要立即就给它补涂啊，
要不然它那个就没有那个效果的，就失效了，因为都已经被水冲掉了啊。
有一些听友，你们如果是敏感机的话，可能会觉得之前用的一些产品，
我一涂防晒就有刺痛感，如果是这种听友的话，那就选纯物理防晒，
你看一下它的成分，氧化性加暗化态的，就这两个成分属于剁性的，不太容易被皮肤吸收，
油皮你就选化学或者是物化结合的清爽一点的那种继续，
肝皮的话就建议选那个带保湿成分的，就里头还有肝油啊，透明脂酸的这一类的，就可以了。
大家选的时候千万不要选那种含酒精的那种产品，一定要选择温和不刺激的，
这样对皮肤也会好一点，不要有那种概念，我SPF值越高就越好，
一定要根据我们刚才所说的这些场景和你的皮肤，到底是一个什么样的一个复制，
来去选择你要用的这个防晒的产品和它的SPF值多少，来去搞它，
要不然的话就很容易加重皮肤的负担，你就想在你皮肤上刮腻子，你这皮肤还能好得了，
这真的很容易又发粉刺或者是过敏这种，如果说一旦不小心把自己晒伤了，怎么办？
你猜怎么办？
上周我们医院接着了一个大学生去海边，暴晒了四个小时，没补涂，
他其实涂了，但他忘补涂了，他说他在海边可能晒胃，晒了四个小时，你猜他怎么，
起了以后为大学生，我天，太严重了，这种持续暴晒的皮肤，他真的就不是晒黑的问题了，
朋友们，是你的皮肤结构性塌坊了，我为什么问怎么办，想要给大家一个思考的时间，
因为很多人都是，我晒上了怎么办，冰敷啊，你马上冰敷啊，就拿出了大冰块，往屏上啪一盖，
我就想给大家这么一个思考的时间，不对，这种是不对的，一定要跟大家讲，这样是非常非常不可取的，
这个紫外线呢，它可以穿透表皮，直达真皮层，破坏你的胶原纤维和弹性纤维，你光用那个大冰块，你怎么去直达你的真皮层，
怎么修复你那个胶原纤维和弹性纤维的朋友们，真正没用啊，咱们这边结构性塌坊了，你又把一个饼块又盖上去，
是正确的一个处理方法，立即脱离咱们这个爆晒环境，这是最主要的，第二步就是冷敷降温，
哎，我说这个冷敷降温，不是大冰块啊，不是大冰块，不是你以为以为那个冷，没那么冷，
30度左右的生理盐水或者凉毛巾去冷敷就可以了，刚刚给大家讲，咱们医院不是接着了一个，
他也是，其实他就是晒上了，他回来填面膜，顺便还拿那个饼块在脸上一直游走，
最后就导致他这个毛鞋血管被冻上了，属于盐震也加重了，还平舔了一个冻上大夏舔，
属于是又叠BUFF双重打击了，这个冷敷降完之后，咱们一定要去涂抹一个温和的保湿修护类的产品，
这样才能让咱们这个皮肤快速的缓过来，如果说晒上非常严重，像刚才环环说的那个，
他的那个案例啊，就那种情况你一定要就医了，不是说你自己能处理得了的了，
那如果要是大家只是一个轻微的晒伤，就比如说你出门，玩了一圈爆晒回来之后，
你脸其实是没有什么爆皮啊，肿啊，或者是起枕子等等这些情况的话，你只是轻微稍稍有点烫啊，
或者是你害怕自己也是晒伤，你要给他修复一下，防护一下，那这样子我非常非常建议大家的是一定要敷面膜，
那敷面膜你在面膜的选择上面也是非常关键的，我更推荐大家选用医用面膜，
因为医用面膜的话，他那个配料表是相对比较干净净净的，他没有其他乱七八糟的东西，
对你的那个下肌这个皮肤是非常有好处的，医用面膜其实也就是医用肤料，
在这个选择上的话，市面上无非两种，一种是透明脂酸纳，一种是胶原蛋白类的，那我其实是非常建议大家选择胶原蛋白类的，
胶原蛋白它是可以起到一个维稳和修复的作用的，而且它可以显著的减少紫外线照射引起的皮肤，红斑啊泛红，
它还可以达到一个强效的补水，它能让这个皮肤变得非常的充盈啊，它可以深度的这种补水，
所以说效果也是非常好的，咱们这个晒伤的本质其实就是皮肤出现了这个急性的炎症和屏障的受损，
在晒伤过后，遵从我们刚刚给大家说的先见稳，这个时候不能浮面膜啊，
着痛感缓解之后，就是咱们浮面膜的最佳的时机，为什么说一定要选择这个医庸浮料，
而且最好是含胶原蛋白的嘛，因为那个真的普通的装置号的面膜，它可能含香精防浮剂，
还有一些会此时此刻刺激到你皮肤的成分，容易对皮肤产生一些刺激，或者是它的营养成分过高稳动，
那叫原蛋白就不会，它恰好就是你此时此刻受损的这个皮肤最需要的东西，
而且叫原蛋白本身能在皮肤有微小损伤的时候安全使用，加速你这个皮肤的这个炎症啊，敏感啊和受损的状态，
还能减少这个色尘，就还蛮好用的，其实我感觉晒伤以后不可怕，就是怕瞎操作，
你做好降温，做好这个及时的修复，很快就能回复过来。
那这我也给大家科普一下，就是刚才黄文说的什么叫卸责号，什么叫装置号啊，
装置号的话我们平常用的这种日用化妆品，卸责号的话它那个卸是医疗器卸的卸，
所以说它是一用级别的，只有一用级别的才有治疗和修复，创面护理啊，辅助预核这些功效，
而且它卸责号的话是相对比较严格的，它是必须要在无军的车间里面生产，
而且它卸责号的东西，它是不允许添加任何那些不好的，像刚才黄文说，
正常的那种日化产品，它是其实可以添加一些什么香精啊，辅料啊，乱七八糟那些，
包括甚至有的可以能加一些激素类的那些东西，但是卸责号是完全不可以的，
它配料表是非常干净精减的，它是不允许加那些的，你就想象一下你皮肤晒伤了以后，
你表皮的屏障就已经受损了，你还用那些含激素啊，重金属啊，
这些小做榜做出来的这种就是不合规的这种生产车间，
做出来的不规范的这种面膜的话，你敷在脸上，你相当于就是给皮肤造成了二次的重创，
包括那个它还不是在无菌情况下做出来的，你那个面膜上可能还有细菌，那你正常的，
你要是皮肤玩好无损的话，你去贴这个面膜的话，没有什么问题，
但是你要是这个皮肤是有这个伤口的，是一个受损的这种状态下的话，那它其实是万万不可，
我为什么要在这里面给大家强呢，因为真的很多人它不会选择，不知道我分不清，
觉得面膜待会都一样，其实真的是不一样的，尤其是那个异用面膜，它就不能叫面膜了，
它叫异用肤料，大家一定要分清这个字样啊，是，我发现就是这个事儿，我其实可能我身边好多的女性朋友都推荐我，
也介绍过，当然他们经常还是晒赏了，还是没有做好这个修复，一问就是，
你说那个异用肤料在上哪儿买了，我得去药店吗，我不知道选什么样的，就总感觉怪怪的，
他们就是随手用那种伤用的面膜很习惯，但是让我去用异用的，他也不知道买啥，也不知道上哪儿买，
就错过了最佳的那个修复器自己胡乱铁片面膜，或者是听了我给他们做的科普，
直到不能乱用，就直接不用了，所以这次我跟布丁人在想做这些播客的时候就想了，就直接我们去找一下比较好的品牌，
我们自己去试用过的，觉得很好的，直接给推荐给大家，就免得这个科普又白做了，就是大家知道了，不能乱贴，
在贴异用的，但是不知道上哪儿找异用的，咱们就直接直把一点推荐给大家一个产品，大家可以去看一下，以它为标准，去选择其他的异用的也是可以的，
我们推荐这个值，因为我们俩用下来感觉挺好的，就想推荐给大家，那我跟缓缓试用这款异用肤料呢，叫做延续，研究的延续式的续，
它也可以有一种感觉，就是延续你的皮肤的这个保护屏障的，我是这么感觉的这个意思啊，它是一款异用重组胶原蛋白创面肤贴，
那这款面膜其实它是已经进了上海酒院了，是很多院线机构都在使用的一个品牌，我们经常使用那种购物平台上面其实是买不到的，
因为它平时做的都是院线机构，是在医院才能用得到的，就像你做完医美项目以后，医生不是都建议你过去抚一抚这种异用肤料吗，他们都是做这些的啊，
我为什么敢这么给大家推荐这款产品，是因为我真的觉得它非常的好，我前段时间是生病了，
又开始中感冒发烧流鼻涕，流鼻涕得流了一个多月吧，我那个工位上全手的鼻涕，导致我醒鼻涕醒的我鼻子周围全是泛红的还有点爆皮，
我连续用了几天之后，我鼻子周围这个皮肤就真的是一点泛红都没有，出奇的好，一般弄破了之后它不是涂那种化妆品啊什么的，会有遮的感觉吗，也没有，
而且这款产品我用上，它是非常清爽的，干干爽爽的，因为我特别讨厌那种油腻腻的那种产品，这款就没有，它是非常清爽的，而且它就是蟹子号的医用肤料，
而且它还是江苏省蟹子号的医用肤料，江苏省它是非常严格，你只要是过了江苏省的这个，你别的地方的你全都能过，真的是就是非常严格，非常标准了，
所以说我在用它家产品的时候，我有一天我敷着它家面膜睡着了，就根本就不用洗，第二天皮肤也非常好，
但是你要是平时的那种普通的那种面膜的话，你是一定要洗掉的，因为你不知道里面会给你添加什么样的那种成分，
但是这个你就不用去担心它，因为它的配料表示非常非常干净的，而且它的那个胶原蛋白是上了专利的，
所以说大家放心的使用，包括你做完医美项目以后，你晒伤以后，或者你最近的时间是一种敏感机，皮肤状态不太好，你都可以连续的敷上一段时间，是会对你的皮肤有非常非常大的一个改善的。
这个我也用了，反正因为我不是敏感机嘛，我皮肤不要干，适配我的面膜其实还挺少，因为我特别讨厌那种就黏黏糊糊精华，特别堵糊在脸上完了以后洗一段洗半天那种，它这都没有。
它的那个面膜不也是，它不是那种沙白沙白的，我特别喜欢，它是有点淡淡的米黄色的，整个贴下来，敷感很清爽，但是这些都不是重点，我的最大的让我惊喜的感受，我第二天早上起来我白了，因为我最后这种感觉。
我天天露营在户外，虽然我也擦防晒，但是还是很难避免，就被晒黑嘛。
我也用了一些美白的面膜，但是它的那个成分有的我都不太喜欢，就是也是用两片就没太用，而且我觉得这种美白的，基本上你今天晚上贴完第二天美白，其实你就可以不用用了。
它就是应该有一个你今天贴，你第二天皮肤就有一个很大改善的效果的，但是我贴那个前几天我用的一些美白面膜没有，我就没再用。
这个其实我觉得就是从此之下，但我只要它的对于一些受损的皮肤等等等等这些好处，这些我都知道，但是我是一个健康状态的皮肤，我就想着我就当调整一下皮肤的那个状态吧。
没想到第二天白了一个度吧能有，能回到一个礼拜前我的皮肤大概那个感觉了。
这个是我没想到的，虽然我看介绍的时候说它能白，但是毕竟重铸汉蛋白这个成分它不是干美白，这个活的你知道吗。
所以第二天它也不是说变白了，让我感觉我的皮肤变亮了，这个是我没想到的，就还挺开心的。
本身这个胶胺蛋白这个肤料，它是有一种显著减少紫外线或者是激光引起的这种红斑，泛红啊，这种东西的，它是其实是可以减少这种紫外线带来的让你的皮肤不好的这种东西的。
其实它是有这种功效的，所以说才会给你一种它变白的感觉，因为你紫外线晒完之后你本身就会，那它给你抵挡住了的话，其实你不黑就是变白了。
而且我跟你讲，为什么我跟大家说一定要选择胶胺蛋白的这个，不是说透明脂酸的不好啊，是因为你胶胺蛋白的它是有非常强大的一个修复功能的。
如果你要是那种兜兜极的话，其实我是建议你去选择什么透明脂酸那的这种，但是如果你要是平时正常皮肤受损呢，或者说尤其是你做完一枚项目以后，你一定要选择胶胺蛋白的，因为它可以快速的关节，修复你这个皮肤的这个屏障。
它真的是属于是修复这一块的王牌，你普通的那种装字号的那种胶胺蛋白面膜，它的那种修复作用是非常非常有限的。
而且比如说你这个皮肤上面有那种小细纹，小肝纹的话，因为它本身那个胶胺蛋白不是有那种强效的这种不水作用吗？
那它也会让这种小细纹、肝纹会没那么明显，因为你皮肤那个细胞它变充颖了。
那你这个皮肤细胞变充颖了之后那些肝纹、细纹，它就自然而然的，它就没那么明显，它就会减少了。
但是你这个可能是要长期的使用。我跟大家说，这个一用肤料啊，一天只要用一次就好了。
这东西好，贵好，但是咱们也不用说一天付好几次，一次就好了，一次是五到二十分钟，这样子，可以非常非常好的给大家起到一个维稳、舒缓，然后还有修复的一个作用。
可能还会叠加像黄昏说的这种很美白的效果，意外的惊喜算是。
我其实有个问题，因为这个面膜是布丁给我的，我不知道上哪儿买。
我刚才听布丁说什么都是各大院线的，这真不是给大家做效果，我也想知道一下你是怎么来的。
因为我是跟这个品牌创始人是认识，是好朋友，我们要过他做这个品牌的这个初心，他的初心想做一个不被原料鼓吹的这种营销的产品。
他不做任何噱头，实实在在做产品的这样一个，而且他家里人也有在医院工作的，是专业，咱就是说。
我们这一期也是和咱们的演续品牌有了一个合作的机会，我给教大家两个福利，一个是通过我们给到的这个链接，我们会在short notes里，我们的听众听友群给到专属的一个群团团的一个链接。
通过这个链接，我们就可以下单给到大家一个20元的优惠券，如果在节目上线的前三天我们就下单的话，我们确认收费以后还会额外的再享受10元的反线活动，加起就是30块钱的一个优惠。
第二个是我们会在评论区抽取三名信的小听众，每个听友群我们再抽取一名小听友送上我们这个演续医用重组教员蛋白的一个创面服贴一盒给到大家，所以就希望大家在评论区永远的留言，咱还有这活动服了一趟，我从不知道。
但我想知道从咱们这个福利价买和去正常现价，你不是说那个医院里有卖的吗？是哪个更便宜，哪个更划算一点？
首先医院的话不是全国所有的医院都有，这个是肯定是没有的，只是有医院是有这个的，但是你不是说所有医院都有，比如说你上海酒院有吧？
那你不可能特意去上海酒院咱买这个，对不对？
然后你现在去上海酒院买的话，它是没有我们这个节目的福利的，就是正常价，是没有给到任何福利的，所以就只有在我们这里买，它才有这样的一个福利，所以大家一定要把握这次机会。
好的好的，那咱们的医用赋料就先推荐到这里，我们接下来再进入正题，夏天最常见的这种防晒我们讲完的话，那还有一个我觉得是很容易出现的一个夏季的户夫的问题就是闷斗，我真的是之前没有斗。
后来来这边可能是因为天气太热了，经常出油也多，油性皮肤导致，我真的很容易长斗斗，我不知道有多少人和我有一样的这个问题啊，但是我真的是在这个治疗斗斗这个上面我是非常有坏权的，你一定一定不要再破坏你这个已经受损的这个皮肤这个屏障了。
闷斗最主要的原因就是高温出油加上毛孔堵塞，咱们最重要的一个处理的原则就是温和清洁，不要选择那些刺激性比较强的那种的强效的清洁，那也是用不着，我们出完汗之后我们也要用清水的清清擦拭，而不是用力的这么拿那种粗料的那种毛巾还夸夸就擦脸啊这样子，这样的话就更容易起斗。
还有就是好多人都以暴之暴，我身边好多一到夏天他这个闷斗严重了，他就拿那个硫黄皂洗脸，洗到已经干到起皮了，他还觉得效果非常好，结果就是皮肤屏障直接就干闷斗了，他过后反射性的那个出油情况会更严重。
夏季护肤的最重要的一个护肤的底层逻辑就是保护皮肤屏障，因为你看无论是你晒上也好，还是说你闷斗也好，你最重要的原因就是你的皮肤屏障受损了。
其实就不仅是闷斗问题，好多人他其他的一些皮肤问题，一到夏天他就会反反复复的发作。
夏天的这个温湿度失衡又滚，正常的话夏季平均湿度达到75%的时候，你这个脚趾层含水量的波动超过30%，咱们这个屏障也是又被大折了。
虽然不像之前你用那些产品给他搭固折了，当然就是大折了，没有以前好用了。
防御霉的这个活性也会下降，你可以称之为一种季节性的屏障皮软综合症，就这个是我贬的免了。
那意思大家能给的就行，它是一个季节性的那个皮肤屏障这会就不怎么干活了这种感觉。
那如果你这个时候还觉得哎怎么夏天来了我这个皮肤问题更严重了，我再猛猛的用一些什么又走C1，哎呀又去脚趾了，用刷塑完那啥了就完了。
不要自己去拆自己的城墙，你反复发作的解决方法就是一条，就像布丁刚才说他那个去到南方以后长斗那个那个情况似的，就是做减法。
就停掉所有那些功能性的，不管是美白的，抗老的还是刷算，只做清洁保持防晒，就我们刚刚给大家说的。
其实这个也是希望在大家贯彻到夏天的，因为夏天就皮肤问题本身就躲了，你可能之前没有。
但是如果你总是在夏天做家法的时间长了，你皮肤敏感了，很多问题就接种而至了。
你就是不管有什么问题，咱们做好这个减法，接下来清洁保持防晒，养上两道四周，让这个皮肤自己把这个砖墙一点儿这个结构气回来，这个屏障恢复了。
很多问题就没有了，真的说没就没了。
但是你越是我反复有问题，我越是一会儿用这个，一会儿用那个，反复往上累一家，它就是越来越差。
真的非常建议大家精减互富，强化我们的这个屏障修复能力。
我们可以用一下我们的医用服务，真的是赶尽快的把这个屏障好好的修复一下。
尤其到夏天的时候，你会发现皮肤科的患者就猛增，真的是猛增。
因为天气热嘛，经常会出汗，夏季的湿疹，汗疹，真的非常非常毒。
如果经常会出现那个小汗疹，胳膊上有起那种细细的小红疹子在那个胳膊上，真的是很多很多。
尤其在这边湿度又很高，就弄不掉吧。有的时候，就以前在北方的时候，它不氧，我就会觉得放在那里也没有关系。
来这边之后它会氧，你知道吗？哎，这种就没办法啊，就可能你也是汗太多了。
即使把这个汗冲洗掉，也是温和清洁，就用水就行。
赶紧冲洗完了以后，擦上一些保湿的，先这样保湿干燥吧。
但是夏天其实还挺难的，最关键的还是你要保护好你自己的皮肤屏障。
到夏天的时候，这个问题可能会轻一些。
以前会洗澡的时候经常粗啊，一顿粗啊，使用那种那种很多那种洗澡的工具，什么磨砂膏啊，
一顿往身上护，现在也是不会了。
就真的是其实的把汗弄干啊，给它清理干净，简单单的给它做一个保湿，就玩事儿。
现在步骤越来越简单了。我常用的唯一乳真的超好用，朋友们。
也推荐给大家。
夏天像说的这种瞎折腾完之后，好多人就是不管之前是干皮，还是油皮，还是混油，
都变成敏感肌了。这个敏感肌一到夏天就更完。
夏天，大家特别像你们在南方空调根本停不下来，就在空调房里进进出出。
这个冷热一刺激，哎呀，这个皮肤特别难受。
我们刚才不就给大家讲了，在家洗脸的时候，千万不要像往上水冷水热水那么交替洗嘛。
但是其实你到夏天的话，你就进出空调房，就跟你在家冷冷水交替洗脸。
那个损伤是一样的。你这个脚趾城，我们刚刚说了，就环顿用温度在五分钟之内，
骤变十五度的时候，这个脚趾城就会出现那个变相解景，你这个屏障就又出现裂痕了。
你看我们整期博客一直在说皮肤屏障，皮肤屏障。
大家应该听到这里能感觉到了，就所有问题出现之前，都是皮肤屏障出现裂痕了。
对，所以这个夏天这个冷热交替也是要注意，特别是敏感肌。
如果你越冷越热都会泛红，涂什么都疼，外油内感锁不住水。
换季就比如说夏天已经过去了，但换到秋天你脸又过敏了。
就我刚刚说的这些情况下，如果你重三天以上，你就是敏感肌。
你就别挣扎了，就赶紧去皮肤课去看一看嘛。
这个已经不太是你自己能调理好的了。
如果说没重三天以上，就可能是偶尔会有一两条两三条那种情况下的话。
给大家的修复方案就是，夏天的时候你一定要温和的降温。
常温的纯净水，搞那种沙布或者是那个化妆棉，轻轻的冷敷五分钟，一定一定不能用冰块。
还有我们刚刚说的减法，护肤做减法，暂停所有功能性的护肤品。
只涂含神经线和泛蠢的这种修护乳。
像布丁说的涂那种唯一乳也可以，它的成分就更简单，更安全。
解面的水温也不要超过你自己的体温。
你手摸上去不冷也不热就可以，一定一定要避免。
我们刚刚说那种造极的解面的产品，最好就是清水洗。
如果要用的话，就用那种暗击酸类的。
如果你现在正处于敏感器的话，你的防晒一定要用物理防晒为主。
就那种物化结合就别用了，就纯物理。
物理防晒其实就有点假白，你可以少涂一点。
可以多用一些物理性的防晒，带帽子，打散，穿防晒衣这些都可以。
在空调房里的话，你一定让那个空调房的温度不要太低，
也不要让这个冷风直接吹到你的面部或者是皮肤。
比如说在空调房里，我就是迟不迟的这个面部就干燥了。
你可以加图这个保湿，提高你这个保湿的频率，
但是也是成分一定要简单，大概就这些吧。
反正我觉得夏天对于敏感机来说还是挺难过去的。
所以一定要小心，因为这个夏天你没过好，你可能，
哎呀，马上秋天，其实秋天马上就感对敏感机更不友好，
你可能马上秋天刚来就过敏了，感觉好不容易熬过了夏天，
然后秋天一来又崩了，所以一定要度过好这个夏天吧。
对，敏感机最主要的就是你要好好地保护你的这个皮肤屏障，
这是第一点，第二点的话，我觉得你还要把自身的免利提高起来。
第三点的话就是不要瞎搞乱搞乱用一些乱七八糟的产品，
把皮肤和肯皮肤屏障给它搞坏掉，你要养起来。
尤其在夏天的时候，你要把你的皮肤养起来，
还有一点的话，你一定要多喝水，
吃到的话你也可以喝一些还有电解质的饮料补出水分，
真的是很好，再给你防晒哦，我真的是挺建议大家用物理防晒的。
我不知道大家有没有观察过那些专职的司机，那些老司机，
他们穿那个半袖啊，半袖里边的皮肤和外边胳膊的下臂和上臂，
它完全是两个颜色，而且就中间有一个很深的那一条的那个分界线，
因为他们长期开车的时候，那个胳膊晒的，就真的是很明显的那个，
这也体现了物理防晒的一个重要性和它的这个效果，
真的是谁也没有那个专职司机，它的那个广告打得好，
真的是你穿着衣服的和你裸裸在外边的皮肤，就完全是一个天一个地啊，
一个白一个黑这样子。
现在也有很多的那种防晒帽做的也都现在非常好看了，
还有那个眼镜啊，还有做那种面部那种叫什么脸鸡泥吗，
就那种东西吧，那我倒是也没用过，
因为我没有那种出去爆晒的那种场景需要用这种东西，
但是我看到有卖那种，大姐其实还挺好看，
因为我有个闺蜜，他天天去钓鱼，他喜欢钓鱼，
搞的那种防晒的装备特别多，很好看哪。
虽然说穿了这些东西之后，他也就是非常的美，非常的漂亮。
Beautiful，所以大家其实完全可以用起来这些东西的。
如果你要是不愿意穿这种防晒衣的话，
其实现在流行很多非常好看的那种女生，那种长袖的那种罩衫，
其实他也有一定的功效，
他们就是说他可能防晒效果没那么好，
但是你想象一下你穿的长袖和你半袖的话，
其实效果也是不一样的，
稍微折扇一点嘛，
就不把皮肤整个的裸露在外边，
其实他还是有一定功效的，
我真的是建议大家搞一搞。
除了这些物理防御，
还有我们刚刚讲的整个这个护肤的流程啊，
防晒爽啊等等这些东西以外，
我觉得皮肤上的问题，
讨多都把注意力放在涂涂摸摸上，
但是都不忘吃上使劲。
我作为一个医院的临床观察人员，
我觉得其实饮食和生活习惯的改变，
对皮肤影响是最大的。
我们单位好多那些减肥的小姑娘们，
他们借了一段时间的甜品奶茶那些东西，
不管是豆的问题啊，还是皮肤状态的问题啊，
还是年轻程度啊，还是胖瘦的问题，
就马上两个礼拜你就能看见效果。
我突然想想，
大家可以多吃一些番茄和蓝莓，
它可以用美白做的，因为它是抗氧了一些水果，
而且特别好。
番茄的话，煮熟的效果更好，
哦，朋友们，
是吗?
你说的这个抗氧化，
它主要起效果的是番茄红素，
煮熟的番茄红素，
它的人体的生活利用度是更高的。
啊，那这我还真不知道。
我单位同事有一个，
他不知道这个事之前，
他每天都抱着一盒小番茄炫，
最近他知道了以后，
他就把他的小番茄都放到他的那个，
养成狐狸煮一下，
要抱着养成狐炫。
不敢跟你说的就是未来的我。
哈哈哈，是，
番茄，蓝莓，
和绿茶，绿茶也是，
茶多分也可以，
抗氧化，
反正这些都能减少，
紫外线幼岛的这个氧化应激反应，
还有就是不停前面说的多喝水，
少量多次，
就保持这个身体的这个，
高水分水和的状态，
有一些光敏性的食物，
我看是网上提出来的，
如果大量涉入，
会有光毒性反应，
芹菜，香菜，无花果和柠檬，
但是我对这个，
保持怀疑太多，
因为我觉得，
这种得抱盆尺，
才能出现他们说的这种情况。
大家只要是正常尺，
其实不用太考虑这个问题，
最主要对就是，
得借糖我觉得，
就是耐茶，
蛋糕哇，
那种糖油混合物类的，
精致的那种小点心，
都要避免，真的。
你就借，就听我的，
借两个礼拜，
你自己的皮肤，
马上能给你最大的反馈，
就算瘦不瘦先不瘦，
你借掉这种高Gi食物，
借掉这个糖，
你第一时间，
你的皮肤就能给你反馈，
可能后面才是，
体重啊，身材上的变化，
但是皮肤这个，
真的反应特别快，
因为这个糖化反应，
它就是会让，
咱们体内的这个，
胶原蛋白变脆，
加速它这个，
老化和消亡，
你只熬不吃了，
这个糖化反应，
马上就消失了，
两礼拜，
你皮肤上，
马上就显现，
而且就像是，
你刚才说那个光明，
那个食物那个，
我也是有这种感受，
你吃就那么点儿玩，
我觉得，
你不用说必须，
必须要闭光啊，
怎么样的，
什么的，
你要少吃，不用，
你就正常，
你爱吃你就多吃，
你不爱吃你就少吃，
正常,
但是有一点，
比如说，
大家用了酸的那个，
互补品，
就含酸类的，
产品的话，
你一定要闭光，
尽量你在晚上使用，
不要白天使用，
这个是你一定要闭光的，
千千万万一定要闭光，
对韩维希的那个，
你也是要闭光，
所以我感觉，
他说那个柠檬，
可能是不是因为，
那个柠檬里面就，
哎哟,
维希可能比较多，
还是怎么着，
我一直在想，
为什么这些，
食物要闭光，
我一直在想这个问题，
如果你用了，
含酸的，
这些产品，
互补品之类的，
那你就一定一定要，
在晚上用，
千万不要在白天用，
一定一定要闭光，
这个时候，
就更要注重防晒了，
还有一个事，
夏天最好少熬夜，
因为我发现，
我夏天，
特别容易熬夜，
因为夏天，
经常,
跟朋友约着出去，
吃小夜呀，
露串呀，
啥的,
就很容易很晚才回家，
就会导致熬夜，
你像冬天，
天黑还早，
也不出去，
就反而不熬夜，
在夏天，
熬夜非常不好，
因为熬夜会让，
皮脂纯升高嘛，
那咱们这个皮肤，
其实也是需要，
这个夜间修复的，
你熬夜，
皮脂纯升高，
会导致这个，
皮肤这个夜间修复能力，
会下降到，
百分之三十以上，
朋友们，
你就你可能，
你用了好贵的面霜，
它也没提升了，
百分之三十，
但是你熬夜为夜就完了，
就三十就没了，
这个皮脂纯，
它主要是受，
激素,
遗传,
和内分泌，
引速,
调控的，
不是说，
它是,
含水分的含量，
所调控的，
它是,
通过这三样，
来调控的，
那你如果，
要是经常熬夜的话，
那你内分泌，
就会失调，
你内分泌失调，
你这个，
油脂的这个分泌，
就会增高，
你这个，
熬了夜，
皮脂纯，
啊,
增高,
油脂分泌，
增多,
好,
那你这个，
皮肤的整个状态，
就会不好，
你就不再多水，
没有用，
嗯,
就大概这些都，
哎,
突然就又都，
串起来了，
哈哈哈，
我们前面讲的内容，
是不是，
这期主打给大家的是，
一个,
如何保持皮肤，
健康的一种，
喧道吧，
嗯,
属于这种，
那布丁，
你给大家，
嗯,
咱们今天，
最主要的就是，
讲了,
夏季户夫的，
核心要义，
就是,
惊减,
高效,
哦,
我们的防晒，
就是我们的，
重争之重，
控油,
和补水，
我们要，
两手抓，
那在说到，
防晒的时候，
我们一定要，
追寻,
A,
B,
C,
原则,
第一个，
避免,
我们长时间的，
暴晒,
物理防晒，
最后一步，
涂抹,
我们一定要，
涂防晒霜，
晒后72小时，
是一个，
黄金的窗口期，
我们一定要，
先降温，
然后,
维稳,
最后再，
修复,
最好的话，
我们是要，
贴一个，
一用的肤料，
来去,
给它进行一个，
维稳修复，
大家,
千万千万，
不要心急，
要慢慢的来，
对于一些，
敏感机的话，
我们要，
少折腾，
用温和的，
清洁的一些，
解面,
精减,
肤浮,
千万不要晒上，
也是,
有条件的话，
就可以，
贴一个，
一用的一个，
复料,
去给它维稳，
修复这样子，
在,
控油和，
补水上面，
我们,
一定不要，
跟自己，
叫劲,
越洗,
越有,
要减少，
造机的一个使用，
使用,
温和的，
解面产品，
千万不要，
造机,
最后一点，
在饮食和，
睡眠上，
我们要给它，
做到一个，
底层的支撑，
一定要把，
水喝够，
糖要少吃，
酵也要早睡，
完美,
呵呵,
鼓掌,
反正大家，
就记住啊，
这个皮肤，
它也是一个，
活的器官，
是你自己，
省上的一个器官，
它有那个，
自我修复的能力，
你别老替它，
干活,
也别帮到忙，
咱们这个，
夏天,
护肤就是，
少折到，
多防护，
精准出击，
大概就是这个样子。
那节目最后呢，
我再跟大家说一下，
本期是有福利给到大家的，
那第一个呢，
是通过，
家庭有群，
和我们给到的一个链接，
进入专属的一个，
群团团的链接下单，
就可以享受，
二十元的优惠券，
啊,
如果在节目上线的前三天，
我们下单，
延续,
一用重组，
胶原蛋白，
创免敷贴一盒，
希望大家能在，
评论区，
踊跃的留言，
分享自己的，
夏季呼呼经验，
大家还可以，
通过收脑词，
添加我们的微信，
进入到我们的，
听友群，
和我们的，
评论区，
一名,
幸运的小听友，
送上我们这个，
延续,
一用重组，
胶原蛋白，
创免敷贴一盒，
希望大家能在，
评论区，
踊跃的留言，
分享自己的，
夏季呼呼经验，
大家还可以，
通过收脑词，
添加我们的微信，
进入到我们的，
听友群，
和我们的，
听友一起唱聊，
那今天，
我们就先，
浅浅的，
聊到这里，
咱们下期再见，
拜拜,
来了,
早点回要，
摄影 really really,。
come on,。
why's brought,。
it's not,。
they brought with me,。
你,
没想到
后来,
别动了，
你,
说出来，
我用,
A叫你,
肚子 lot僵前一伤，
school kinda beating。
物体运萤力大少，
好 deal,
修吃饭，
种木呼，
咱俩都拉完仇恨了。
这游泳
你这不才没流行两年吗？
你只让它再流行
你这是咱俩
别一次一期节目给自己。
造成那么多对立面读不好。
人家子弹弹的一会儿没了。
快住嘞
住嘞
那布丁你给大家
最后再从头到尾总结一下吧？
突然总结
这游泳
你这突然高等于
你这游泳就是
老师最后下课的时候。
就给你点瓶
你这我今天都讲什么了。
你给我付出一遍
对不起
你说你没准备
得亏不是公开课
公开课我都没让你下课。